so a lot of consequences maybe we
haven't thought through of this pandemic
and one of them is countries to our
south could be destabilized by it and
you could see a surge a big surge of
illegal immigration come up from Latin
America if that does happen and it
absolutely could happen are we prepared
to deal with it mark Morgan is acting
commissioner of Customs and Border
Protection and he joins us sentenced
Morgan thanks very much for coming on
this does not seem like a crazy
possibility it's very easy to imagine
that a place like Mexico which doesn't
seem to be doing anything to protect the
population is flouting any any
suggestion that they lock anyone down
but they could have massive problems
with this what would that mean for us
well tuck you're spot on it's not
hyperbole to think about that but what I
want your listeners to know this isn't
the first infectious disease right SARS
h1n1 and what we do CBP as well as other
governmental agencies look we we hope
for the best
we plan for the worst and that's exactly
what we're doing now so we know that
that could be a possibility so we're
taking aggressive containment and
mitigation strategies now to hope stem
that if that should become a possibility
and the president's authority and his
agreement with the CDC order last Friday
is doing just that in six days Tucker
it's amazing what we've accomplished
there overall people trying to enter our
country illegally in six days because of
the CDs order CDC's order that the
president approved has dropped 50% and
another key stat if you don't mind is is
our vehicular traffic and our
pedestrians actually both of the
northern and southern border has dropped
by over 65 percent that means the
Mexican citizens and the Canadian
citizens as cells are actually self
policing and doing that the medical
experts say and they're staying home and
that's because of this president and the
CDC's order right I mean to be fair
though those are mostly people who obey
the law coming up from Mexico legally
every day or and and in from Canada I
wonder are you seeing a drop in what
we've heard for the last three years
from Democrats which is it's immoral to
keep anybody out to enforce borders
borders themselves are immoral because
no one's illegal are people saying less
of that kind of non
since now the coronavirus is here so
it's it's it it's interesting Tucker
because for a long time we've been
saying borders matter and we were
talking about that we've been talking
Hey
drugs are porn in this country killing
68,000 people last year we have bad guys
criminals gang members porn in but we've
also been saying that that infectious
disease coming across the borders a real
threat as well but people are dismissing
and they weren't listening but they're
listening now it's that really the third
part of that that stool and effects the
disease it's important and it does
matter secure borders matter as we just
saw in a second we did on New York
leaders in some places don't care if you
get sick they're never going to protect
you because it makes them feel guilty
unbelievable mark Morgan great to see
you tonight thank you you bet thank you